All right.
So good morning everyone.
Thank you for,
uh,
for joining me and thank you Google for hosting visa presentation.
Um,
today I want to tell you a little bit about what happened when I decided to,
um,
open open source,
my book in how you can leverage the same approach to,
uh,
publish your own book.
Um,
so as a handyman mentioned,
my name is Francesco Marconi.
I'm a media strategies in recently published leave like fiction,
um,
30 days to become the author of your own life story.
Uh,
the book is essentially an interactive guide on how to find purpose,
creativity,
and inspiration through storytelling.
Uh,
the organizing principle of,
of this book is called engage,
uh,
because this book is about how to engage with yourself in how to engage with the
things around you that inspire you.
Uh,
any sauce with the acronym for each of the six parts that comprise the book in
those six parts are,
um,
explore your meaning,
narrow your goals,
uh,
generate a plan,
anticipate roadblocks,
gain persistence in elevate yourself.
So the book is comprised of fat of six major sections with the five mini
chapters each.
Um,
so total 30 mini chapters,
one for each day of the month.
So it's designed to be a month long program.
Um,
in these chapters,
tell the an interesting story of an [inaudible] people,
including artists,
entrepreneurs,
thinkers,
authors in and veal,
um,
the strategy behind their accomplishments.
In finally each brief question,
each brief section concludes,
we think any interactive exercise so the reader can apply what they just learned
or what they just,
um,
and reflected on.
So one of the questions that I get the most when I'm presenting my book,
we're talking about it.
Um,
it's not necessarily about the contents in the book because people end up
reading it,
uh,
but it's more about the process or the approach that I took to publish the book.
In fact,
someone recently told me that a book is like the new business card.
So you need the book,
uh,
in our to,
transacting in the business world.
So I want to tell you today how you can write your own book using this
methodology that I,
um,
that I follow for a four.
Leave like fiction.
Before I do that,
I just wanted to guide you through how traditional traditional book publishing
works.
Uh,
any something like this.
Um,
the author writes a sample or a sample chapter in a proposal,
partners with a literary agent,
um,
who helps the author broker the deal.
We the we,
the publishing house.
And then finally,
much later the book is released to the audiences and they read the book.
So in these traditional approach,
the reader is actually the last person to come into contact with,
uh,
what he just created.
And this is a great approach if you're already a well known person in and have a
big following.
So if you're a former president,
a famous chef and award winning author,
this is great for you.
But if you're like me and he are just the irregular person,
um,
you have to build interest in,
you have to build an audience before you even think of,
of publishing a book.
And that's where,
um,
a new approach comes handy,
uh,
which I call iterative,
iterative approach.
And so for my book,
I decided to flip the model,
start with the audience first,
um,
and collect feedback from,
from people that read sort of the,
the genesis of the book in take those insights to improve it,
uh,
before,
partnering with a book publisher to amplify distribution.
And so this is,
um,
for those of you who are familiar with a product development techniques like
design thinking,
that's exactly what,
what I applied here.
So too,
I want to share with you today how iterative published can help turn your ideas
into a successful book.
Um,
and uh,
the book,
uh,
or,
or the process starts precisely by,
uh,
creating a proof of concept.
So,
um,
an idea that you can test,
receive feedback and then improve based on that.
So the first step or the first thing to consider when you're developing your own
book project,
he start with purpose,
um,
event defying things that are important to you.
So something that gives meaning to your life or a,
an ambition or,
or a personal goal.
In my case,
uh,
when I was young,
I have a dream of one day leaving in New York City.
I'm in so much so that when I was 16,
um,
I decided to buy a picture of New York City's of the New York City skyline,
which you see on that picture,
um,
on the slides and hang it above my,
my Beth,
this is my,
uh,
my childhood,
a bathroom and I'm having this picture,
um,
help me visualize a goal or an ambition that I have.
And eventually I was fortunate to turn that dream into a reality when I got a,
an internship here in New York City.
But when I finally arrived to the city of dreams,
um,
I really didn't know anyone.
I was just fresh out of college.
I had no professional experience.
So my way of coping with the situation was to write my observations of how
people behave,
how the,
the small talk,
how they inspired others,
how the managed people in.
So I started translating these interesting observations that occurred around me
into strategies that I could use in my own life.
Um,
and so those notes,
literal notes that I wrote became the raw material of what eventually became a
leave like fiction.
So a few tips here as you're getting started in your book project,
find the personal,
um,
story that illustrates your,
your journey in,
make it surprising in authentic.
So once you have figured out that,
um,
your purpose,
the second step is essentially to test,
to test those ideas,
um,
at scale.
And so you,
uh,
a good way of doing that,
these actually engineer a viral post.
It might seem challenging,
but,
uh,
if you follow some,
some,
some ideas here,
uh,
it's not,
it's not that difficult.
So,
uh,
think about it.
A virus,
these viral PLO post or this,
um,
summary of,
of what your book wants you want to accomplish in your book as a teaser for what
do you want to develop a,
and this is important to have a early validation because you will be able to
collect feedback and success metrics.
Uh,
for example,
how many people share the article or liked it or how many views you got.
So you can share those metrics within eventual publisher down the line.
So as,
as I mentioned before,
I have,
um,
developed a playbook of strategies from my observations on how to have better
communication skills,
leadership,
um,
influencing people and,
uh,
decided to take those notes that I,
that I end written and put them on a online,
a shared document.
And then what I did is that I sent it to 10 friends and I asked them to provide
me feedback,
uh,
in most importantly to highlight the areas of,
of,
of that article or the blog posts that were the most unique,
the most compelling.
And so I let the audience,
uh,
although it was a small audience of 10 people initially participate in the
creative process,
it's almost like testing your,
your product before it's released to the public.
So I invited feedback,
12 media Antifa by the,
the ingredients in those notes,
uh,
that worked in and then use those to improve the overall narrative of,
of the pilot or,
or the post that would originated blog,
the book.
So when I find it finally published online,
um,
I used medium.
Uh,
there aren't many other platforms.
I knew that the version that I had just published was the best version that I
could create because they've,
um,
a lot of the elements that people enjoyed and,
and highlighted as the most unique,
the most surprising.
And eventually the,
the,
the blog posts became a viral.
So what happens when you are at the stage and final year of your viral blog
posts,
which is almost a teaser for the book.
Um,
you have an opportunity to build a support community,
not only if those 10 initial people,
very west for feedback,
uh,
but also people who,
you don't know yet and I've enjoyed reading your,
your work.
Um,
and it's important to connect with these readers because down the line they will
play a very crucial role in promoting your book once it's out for a,
for sale and end.
In addition to that,
you may get lucky and get people you admire,
uh,
to give you feedback and validation.
So in my case,
journalists,
Katie Couric and author Neil Strauss,
uh,
share their appreciation on Twitter and there was very important to me.
And also when I was discussing it with potential publishers,
I use the says,
uh,
um,
validation for,
uh,
for the potential of the book.
So the,
the thing to remember here is not to be afraid to reach out to the people that
you don't know and that,
uh,
enjoy their work because they will play a crucial role,
in the promotion of the book.
Uh,
down the line.
The step,
the fourth step that I want to share with you is how to amplify your audience.
So remember,
you have this initial interest around the viral viral posts.
You have to extend your 15 minutes of fame,
uh,
by publishing your ideas through different online publications.
So in my case,
I have that successful blog post on medium in,
I use the engagement metrics.
I actually took a screen shot of,
of the metrics are many views on many shares in.
I sent it to a few online magazines and uh,
convinced them to republish,
um,
my,
my article on their site.
So eventually some of these brands,
um,
invited me to continue as a contributor,
uh,
which gave me a fantastic opportunity to get exposure to,
many more people.
So a few tips here as you're looking to expand your audience through,
um,
different online magazines.
It's very important to start with a friend.
We publisher,
maybe it's a,
a friend who met before or it's someone who works at those magazines.
You met Annie at an event,
and then once you secure the first,
the first,
uh,
publishing partner,
um,
Ben,
it's much easier to get others because you already have the validation of some
of those brands.
And so you have to repeat the process,
um,
and keep generating interest around your work.
All right,
so,
um,
this was the first stage of validating your concept,
your book concept with the potential audience,
and then amplify it through,
uh,
through different collaborations.
Uh,
now what,
how the turn that audience in that interesting to a book veal.
So,
um,
since my book originated online as,
as a,
as a blog,
it was important for me to give it some more structure in show publishers that,
uh,
it was much more than a viral post.
Um,
and so I,
what I did was to find an organizing principle.
As I mentioned at the beginning.
Um,
that organizing principle is engaged,
which is an acronym for each section of the book.
Um,
and this acronym or this organizing principle is very important,
uh,
because,
it helps you summarize the key ideas in your book.
Um,
in my case there are related to storytelling,
inspiration,
creativity,
strategy,
uh,
in so engage,
links up to that very well.
Um,
finding an acronym is ease is crucial because,
um,
it makes your work more memorable for your readers,
but also it differentiates it from any other books or publisher might be
evaluating once you presented to them.
All right.
So step six,
um,
is,
is very important,
uh,
particularly nonfiction books,
which is the case of,
of live like fiction,
uh,
is to make them a more,
um,
uh,
two sided experience.
So not only the reader is going through the,
the stories in the book,
but they are also taking action.
Uh,
my approach to find inspiration to turn some of the,
the,
the stories in the book into potential,
um,
exercises was to actually run offline workshops.
And he's here a picture there,
uh,
where I'm running a workshop at a,
at a local startup community.
And so,
uh,
what I did was to turn the offline interactions that I had with people and with
participants of,
of those workshops,
um,
into exercises that I could include in the book,
in these can be applied to many other areas.
So,
you know,
in my case,
it's a book about strategy and storytelling.
If you're writing a book,
the book about computer science or programming or,
or marketing,
you can find ways of everything your readers apply,
the lessons you're,
you're sharing with them and not an important point.
If you noticed at the beginning,
the book has a very,
um,
uh,
rich,
design element.
And that's,
that's crucial because,
um,
nowadays a book is not just a,
something you really saw salsa,
an object,
uh,
that people want to carry with them.
So the design element,
these,
uh,
as crucial for the success of the book is the content itself.
All right,
so you have,
you have all of these interests,
then you have,
um,
and you have the metrics in,
you have an organizing principle,
the um,
and you package your ideas very firmly.
Uh,
now we can turn them,
turn all of those success metrics into a book proposal.
Um,
and so a book proposal,
uh,
it's like,
or eat,
it is a business plan where you had to provide an overview of what you're
working on,
the audience you're trying to reach.
Um,
who is your competition?
So are there other books out there that are similar to yours?
Uh,
and even I'm a go to market strategy.
So how are you,
once the book is,
um,
is,
in,
in the bookshelves and in the stores,
how do you promote it?
Uh,
and you know,
the best analogy that I have for these informed my experiences,
almost like you have a small startup in your pitching it to investors in,
in this case,
the investors are,
uh,
the book publishing companies,
right?
So finally we have gone through this,
this process of building an audience,
creating a proposal you were successful at,
at selling that proposal,
any identifying it,
publishing partner,
how do you promote the book,
um,
and how do you do it in a cost efficient way.
And this was,
this was particularly important to me being cost efficient and time efficient
because I have a full time job.
So I took some of the,
the,
the skills that I have in,
in media strategy,
in applied,
um,
uh,
content in mark in a strategy principles to the promotion of the book.
So one of the things that,
um,
is crucial is your launching the book is to keep your audience interested,
your initial audience.
Remember of the people that follow view that liked your blog post.
Um,
and a great way to keep a very interesting these to um,
develop a newsletter.
Uh,
I found that a very simple way of writing newsletters that get a lot of
engagement is,
uh,
by setting automatic alerts on Google search for news articles that highlight a
ideas related to the concepts that are you exploring in,
in your book.
So for example,
I,
I have a lot of alerts for things related to storytelling,
east ration strategy.
And then what do you do is,
is to curate those articles.
You summarize them and you share,
share them with your following.
Newsletters are also very important because,
uh,
there are great tools for a running small promotions like giveaways,
in a,
in an even asking for favors.
So for example,
asking form,
uh,
your readers to share a link to an Amazon page with their friends or to leave a
testimonial on your site and so on.
Um,
this is one of the,
the last one of the few,
few last things that I want to share.
We do a,
which he's trying to do,
trying to create your book as a multi-format experience.
So it started as a,
as a,
a written worth project.
Uh,
but the reality is audiences want to engage with more visual formats,
uh,
specifically video.
Um,
and people want to enter to be entertained and learn the long along the way.
So I use the video automation tool called a whippets.
And essentially what these,
uh,
very simple to use,
um,
uh,
software allows you to do is to summarize,
um,
the book,
the chapters in your book,
um,
find related images and package them into very engaging,
uh,
shareable social videos.
So,
uh,
also related to engaging people with,
with different formats of your book just beyond the print product.
Um,
I find it very,
very powerful to surprise our readers.
And so what I did in,
in this,
um,
in this case was to develop an augmented reality app where readers can drop
inspiring thoughts,
uh,
in their ideas,
in,
um,
in the book,
by pointing their phones at the book cover.
So it's essentially a virtual book club and locked through,
um,
augmented reality.
I'm not sure if the video will play,
but we can,
we can try just so you can see how it looks.
Okay.
Yeah.
So as you,
as you've seen the Biv a year,
he's not bet you need an augmented reality app necessarily,
but a bit you can find interesting ways of,
of uh,
engaging your audience in surprise them along the way.
So,
all right,
so you have all of these,
these interesting activities.
You have a book,
you have an augmented reality app,
your videos,
uh,
what can you do next?
Well,
you can repeat the process either for other projects,
um,
either books or you can do the same thing for other markets.
Um,
so in my case,
um,
I just,
uh,
published the first international version of leave,
like fiction,
we chairs,
uh,
[inaudible],
it's a Portuguese version.
Um,
and he follows,
it,
follows exactly the same,
the same approach.
And um,
I will leave you with the trailer that I made to promote,
um,
the,
the book in Portugal and then we can,
uh,
we can have a discussion in Q and a.
Oh,
all right.
So thank you.
Okay.
All right.
Thank you,
Francesco with these was great.
Um,
so as a reminder to her microphone was on the aisles.
If you want to ask a question just for free and go ahead and ask.
But,
uh,
let me start by asking you,
um,
what,
where did the idea of becoming an author just,
uh,
come from?
Yes.
So the,
my,
my initial objective was not to become an author,
it just,
uh,
really app and organically.
Um,
as I mentioned the first time I moved to New York City,
I didn't really know anyone in.
So one way of coping with this transition to the professional world was to take
notes and how people
behaved in then I'm in different situations,
in social circumstances,
professional circumstances,
and then translate those ideas into,
um,
strategies that I can,
that I could use.
Um,
and then after initially,
uh,
a few,
colleagues and friends and the chance to read it and,
uh,
and encouraged me to share it wider,
and that's where the entire process,
um,
the entire process began.
One thing that I would say is that,
um,
it's very challenging to go through all of it,
but once you do it,
uh,
it becomes very easy to replicate a,
so hopefully I'll be looking to more,
more projects in the future like this.
Yeah,
we too.
Absolutely.
Um,
just in the same line,
um,
who's your favorite author?
Well,
I,
I have many different,
um,
authors that I,
that I like.
Um,
I can pinpoint one specifically,
um,
but,
I'm actually reading a very interesting book called the invention of News,
uh,
which traces back,
which traces them,
uh,
the,
the news industry back to the 13 androids,
uh,
all the way to modern times.
So it's a,
it's,
it's very interesting for me as that's my industry,
but I usually read a lot of nonfiction books.
Right.
That's very interesting.
Um,
well,
I did have a question about your,
your book or a few questions about your book,
but before,
uh,
well you did mention that you wrote a blog post,
right?
It went viral.
So did you ever consider just taking two writing blog posts or just be a
blogger?
Um,
no,
because you know,
the,
the initial,
the initial goal was to see if I could execute on the strategy of turning
something digital into a physical.
Um,
and it was important to me as a personal interest in,
as a media strategist to try to explore different ways of telling a story,
not only through a blog post,
but through a physical book,
uh,
videos and augmented reality APP,
um,
in,
so creating a portfolio of experiences.
Um,
and again,
the most enjoying thing is the,
is the process of figuring out how to do it,
uh,
in to learn about new,
um,
new strategies or new technologies and uh,
and then implement them in,
in,
um,
in the project specifically.
Right.
Okay.
Um,
so now talking about your,
your book teach color.
Um,
did you originally intend to have the book as,
as an open source book or were you,
or did you ever conceive they're having or maybe following the traditional
approach at some point?
No,
the initial goal was,
um,
you know,
if I'm a,
if I'm promoting innovation as part of my,
my professional career in,
if I'm encouraging new ways of thinking of our media strategy,
um,
it would be better if myself,
I,
if I explore new avenues and new routes to,
um,
uh,
to,
to publish content.
So I wanted to,
for the process to be,
uh,
to break away from the traditional model and apply a more user centric,
approach,
uh,
to,
to writing the book.
So putting the audience first rather than then last,
um,
and then,
uh,
use that,
that initial feedback to improve the book in validated before it's distributed
wider.
Bye.
Uh,
by a publisher there.
Right.
Very innovative indeed.
Thank you.
Have a question from the audience.
Yes.
Hello.
Thanks Francesco for coming.
Um,
you mentioned in your talk how you shared your book and the ideas with a group
of 10 people.
How did you actually decide who those 10 people should be?
Because depending on the composition,
that would greatly kind of bias a book one way or another.
We're looking for people who were,
uh,
you knew work a little bit more critical or people who just make you feel good
depending on your [inaudible].
That's a great question.
In a specifically,
uh,
when I was designing these small focus group,
um,
I picked,
uh,
friends who I know are very critical.
Uh,
and in fact the question that I asked was,
tell me what's wrong.
Um,
and um,
and after you do that,
tell me what you like.
And so inviting these feedback and inviting,
um,
the,
the initial work to be dissected in,
evaluated by people that I know are very critical was very important to me
because,
uh,
once it goes through a,
that,
that smell test,
then in you're able to improve your work based on,
on,
on those interactions that then you're likely going to have some something that
everyone enjoys.
Um,
and I also,
I also searched for people or either notified,
uh,
friends and families from different,
from different areas.
So not only people that work in media or entrepreneurship,
but you know,
um,
friends that worked in the medical field and friends who are artists or
teachers.
And so trying to have,
um,
uh,
an audience or initial audience that could represent the y the wider world.
Is 10 a magic number?
Was
it like three friends that,
that like Hugh through France and you know,
like you and maybe mom and dad?
No,
it was not in a magic number.
It was just,
um,
you know,
I was looking for initial,
um,
group of,
of people that could provide,
uh,
some,
some guy than Cindy just step and to be 10.
Uh,
but I think that's a,
that's a good number.
Uh,
I think five,
ease,
too small and um,
you know,
maybe one end.
Are these east too big?
So,
um,
something,
something in between.
Right?
So aspiring writers and authors and people forget that.
Uh,
okay.
So now in the lines of feedback,
how did you prepare for,
for not positive feedback?
I mean,
you,
by doing the book has an open source.
You probably knew that there was a possibility that some of the feedback that
you were going to receive was not necessarily what you wanted to hear or read.
So how did you prepare yourself for that?
Yes.
So,
uh,
two,
two main things.
So the first thing is that the main objective was to produce a very good
product,
a very good book.
And so if that's the focus,
then,
um,
I could look at feedback as a way of improving in getting close to,
to,
to that,
to that vision in the second point is that you don't have to receive,
um,
or implement all the feedback you,
uh,
you,
you get,
so there's a,
there's a a balancing act between the feedback you receive in your own,
um,
uh,
you know,
your own direction,
your own creative spirit.
So you have to be able to manage both of those in a while.
Staying true to your own voice in,
into what do you want to convey in the book that you're writing.
Right.
Okay.
I have to say that's very courageous of you.
Ah,
I'm not so sure if I would just want to open the things our ride to the open net
and see what feedback I get a,
so,
yeah.
Good stuff.
Thank you.
Very courageous.
Um,
okay,
so kinda shifting gears a bit.
Um,
well,
technology is,
is part of your book.
It's,
it's basically at its core.
Um,
when did you decide to incorporate technology in,
in,
in your book?
Uh,
well,
I mean,
it's part of,
uh,
my,
technology is part of my language.
It's,
it's what I do as,
uh,
in,
in my profession.
And so,
um,
you know,
today we have so many tools available to us that can really help us scale our
creativity in these collaboration between humans in,
in machines is something that I'm very passionate about.
Um,
so I wanted to incorporate technology from,
from day one,
uh,
and then means,
um,
using a,
a,
you know,
online shared document to,
um,
you know,
online platform for sharing blog posts,
which in my case was medium all the way to using a video automation in,
in augmented reality.
Um,
in,
as I mentioned,
it was a process of exploration,
not only of the concept of the book,
but what I could do around it in,
um,
the strategies that I could implement,
uh,
as part of this project.
Right.
And then you also mentioned that,
well,
you have a full time job.
So how,
tell us how you balance that.
I mean,
did,
did your job and the associated pres somehow help you achieve what you wanted to
achieve with the book or through the process?
Um,
just tell us how you balance that.
Because I think sometimes,
you know,
we all want to do things,
but oh,
where I'm so busy with my,
with my job that I just can't find the time for just doing whatever,
you know,
whatever I haven't been wanting to do for so long.
So how did you balance?
Yeah,
absolutely.
So first of all,
these was a hobby for me.
Something that I was very interested in pursuing.
Uh,
and you know,
I really enjoy doing it.
And so,
um,
if that's the case and if you're doing an enjoyable activity becomes much easier
when you arrive home after a long day at work in,
you use it as a way of relaxing,
of distracting yourself.
Um,
and that's,
that's what I,
that's what I did,
use these creative process,
uh,
to not only inspired the book,
but also inspire,
uh,
my,
you know,
my daily life in my profession because I,
I,
I feel that having a hobbyist crucial,
uh,
because it's a source of,
of creativity that you can then channel into different areas of,
of,
uh,
of your life.
Uh,
in also there's,
you know,
there's the weekend,
which is a,
a,
a great,
um,
you know,
if you count the number of hours in things that you can accomplish on a weekend,
if it's something enjoyable to you.
Uh,
there's,
there's a lot of time,
uh,
specifically my work as a media strategies.
There's a,
at a large news organization,
I get to learn about a new technologies,
new strategies.
And so,
uh,
some of those lessons learned,
um,
ended up,
playing a role in,
in what you do or in my case or what I did outside work.
Uh,
so learning about video automation in learning about how to develop newsletters
out to curate content.
Uh,
it's something that,
um,
that I was exposed to through my work to.
Do you ever ask your,
your coworkers for feedback about the book?
Uh,
yeah,
absolutely.
And,
um,
in fact,
we have,
uh,
a very successful internship program.
Uh,
and I was,
uh,
the,
my publisher gave me several copies of the books so we could give it to,
to our interns.
Um,
and I've,
I've also shared some presentations in some ideas,
specifically about the book with,
with my colleagues in,
uh,
they have been wonderful at supporting the project as well as providing
feedback,
asking questions in,
in so on.
Again,
a very courageous of you.
Yeah.
Um,
what advice can you give those future authors that are watching this on youtube?
What,
what's the maybe three things you can tell them more?
Or the one thing you can tell them to do?
Those were thinking about,
as I said before,
I started their own project,
but maybe they just don't have,
they think they don't have the time or,
or,
or so,
yeah.
So I think the most important things,
uh,
to develop a plan of,
the steps you want to accomplish,
uh,
and um,
the action items that you have to do or to execute to get to that larger vision.
So for example,
in these discussion today,
I shared,
um,
you know,
10 principles that I found important in,
in,
in my journey.
Um,
I think these are applicable to other people,
but each,
each individual will have their own unique way of approaching a book project.
But again,
if you're able to define a plan and stick to it,
eventually you'll see results.
And that was important to me because I wanted to,
uh,
give up every single day as I was,
creating this project because,
you know,
it's,
uh,
you're getting rejected by publishers or you know,
the feedback is very harsh or you are not able to,
um,
you know,
create a cert,
execute on a certain idea that you had.
So having that guiding principle in there,
knowing what a light at the end of the tunnel in terms of your creative
processes,
um,
is crucial as,
as you're developing a,
a book project or any media
project.
Right.
Okay.
Well,
uh,
have maybe one more question.
If the audience has any questions,
please approach Mike's a yes and we have a question.
Yeah,
thanks for coming.
Um,
I have spoken with a lot of authors and I worked with some of them closely and I
feel a lot of them have gone through this great marathon of creating this,
this work,
this item,
and they sort of run out of energy when it comes time to self promote.
Some of them expect the publisher would you do this?
And it's not a lot of resources and publishing these days to really pull that
through all the way.
What sort of advice would you offer to authors who have gone through the race
and are basically in their mind finish,
but they have a little ways to go and to making their books as success?
What sort of advice do you have to keep their energy levels up in that self
promotion phase,
which I think is just so key that you're talking.
Absolutely.
And um,
that's excellent question because I,
I felt,
uh,
the,
you know,
what you just described,
which is some fatigue after going through all of these Sanford and then,
uh,
you still have to,
to promote the book.
Uh,
one,
one thing that I find very energizing and all do,
I've been talking about how to leverage technology in a different marketing
tools that are available out there.
Um,
I found very,
very rewarding to have offline discussions with,
with people in,
in,
uh,
in readers and potential readers because then you get to interact with,
you know,
with people that are just like you and,
uh,
you get new ideas and you see how,
from,
um,
how they are enjoying reading it in,
in that's,
that's,
uh,
that's inspiring.
And as I'm writing,
um,
you know,
or as I was writing this book in any other projects,
I always think about one or two people,
specific people,
friends or people that I met at an event or at a conference.
Those are,
those are,
that's my audience.
And so I'm thinking about that specific person.
I'm thinking about John or Sarah or whoever it might be.
And I'm in everything that in mind of how will they react once this is out.
So again,
not folk focusing of course on being creative and resourceful in terms of the
technology tools you use to market your book,
but most importantly,
find avenues to interact,
uh,
with people in real life.
Thank you.
Okay,
Francesco,
one last question.
Um,
what's next?
So we know your book is published in Portuguese now,
do you plan to do more,
more versions,
perhaps Italian?
Yeah,
I would love to,
to do more versions in,
um,
you know,
looking forward to finding partners in,
uh,
in readers in,
in,
um,
in other countries because the,
the feedback that I've been getting has been very positive and that's re very
rewarding.
And,
uh,
I would love to share some of some of the ideas in the creativity we even more
people.
So I'm awfully more translated versions in the future.
And any other plans to write more books or other subjects?
Do you have in mind for future?
Yeah,
I have some,
some,
some other ideas,
but,
uh,
right now I'm focusing on and on making these specific project a successful.
Um,
and then I'm sure eventually I'll,
uh,
I'll explore other concepts or other book ideas.
So.
All right.
Well,
thank you so much for coming.
We're definitely appreciate your time and,
uh,
thank you for your ideas with us.
Thank you so much.
And thank you Google for hosting me.
[inaudible].